I'm back live for a short stream today.
I think I'm going to do two shorter
streams
depending on how much stuff I get done.
Uh I want to make this ideally the last
day of writing that I have to do.
Let me open up the uh the chat and open
up the
the article and then I will tell you
what we're doing today.
I am also traveling tomorrow.
So there will be no stream tomorrow
on
and okay.
We finished the draft of this guide.
Between this one and this one, we have
over 20 pages of content.
I'm going to attempt to in the next hour
write the last section, proofread all of
these, make any fixes. Hopefully, I'm
happy with this as it is. Uh, and then
that will be set. I'll have to get
images for these, but otherwise it'll be
set.
And then later today, I think I'm going
to just do the uh the paper edits.
The camera ready.
So, did I actually have 10 sections
here?
No, I didn't. I kind of just put this
random thing.
So, I realized the thing that I realized
that I didn't do is I didn't give you
like some of my super valuable just like
from experience advice on how to do
things all in one place. So, that's the
section I want to add.
because right now we have this intro.
We've got building something simple.
We've got some fundamentals. We've got
build some more stuff. We've got some
more fundamentals. We've got build more
stuff. Got some background material.
And then
Here
we are.
Let me go check our quick start guide
real quick
Yeah. So, a lot of it is kind of this
like the bottom section here.
So, like let me just let's just get the
bullets here, right?
Um,
I don't want to just duplicate this
section, right?
but people are going to want to know
like the
way more specific stuff.
like the way more specific stuff. I'm trying to think how much of that I
I'm trying to think how much of that I
even have.
Like honestly, a lot of the stuff that
makes me good at RL is pretty dang
general.
I mean, it's stuff that like it stuff
that's useful in a lot of places, but
matters a lot more in reinforcement
learning. Like the whole focus on
simplicity and iteration speed and
stuff. It's good to do this in a lot of
general engineering. It's just that like
you get punished way way more heavily if
you don't do this in RL.
Let me go look at like
somebody actually sent me some messages
I believe
in and Discord's got a update.
Check this message from Spencer real
quick.
Where was uh there was a guy that like
posted like a whole bunch of stuff. I
can't keep up with this chat at this
point here.
Generally, when something's really
broken, a bunch of people slap me at it.
Oh, yeah. Here it is.
How to approach
things that don't
agent.
We do like multi- aent.
Is that even like a thing?
valuation.
Yeah, maybe what to log. What are good
logs
observation and action spaces I suppose
Okay.
Let's do like a instead of just doing
bullets, let's do a a paragraph on
Let's just start writing this paragraph
and let's see uh what this does,
where we get with this.
This is
the design of the observations is a
little bit more technical.
Yeah. So, there are bits of this that
are more technical and bits of this that
are more general.
Let's do like how to
So data
If anybody has uh questions,
general RL questions, how to approach
problems or things like they will get
into this guide. If you ask a good
question, I will like put it into here
is the reason I'm streaming writing
which would normally be very boring
otherwise.
Trying to think if there's anything else
I want to add here.
I pretty much covered all of this
already.
I can actually it's like two sentences.
I have no experience in this space but I
find this all very interesting. Thanks
for taking the time to contribute this.
Yeah, I gotcha. It's um I don't do a ton
of educational content. Most of my stuff
is like how do we push the cutting edge
of research, but a lot of it has been at
this point like contributors jumping
aboard and helping us with stuff. So, I
figured I'd give a little bit back to
those people. And then also, I hope that
this will get more people interested in
uh the research side and helping with
all the stuff that we're working on as
well. This is going to be like 20 to 30
pages of uh material released with this
guide. I think what we'll do is we'll do
it for 10k uh 10k followers because
we're almost there.
Okay, I'm going to just read I'm going
to I think I got like half an hour left
before my uh my meeting almost. So, I'm
going to
I'm just going to read through this
whole thing.
I'm going to actually read through the
other one as well. I'm gonna see. I
think I have just enough time to do that
and we'll see if I think it's done.
So, by popular demand,
right,
by popular demand, I wrote a uh a second
article
if you have time to answer. Oh, want to
chat this afternoon? Yeah, Spencer, I
can do that. You have time to answer.
What's the background motivation of this
guy's target audience? Uh, I mean, we
just have a lot of new people that have
been asking me and like people come into
Puffer from all sorts of different Where
is it? all sorts of different
backgrounds here. Like people ask me for
this one because some people are new to
a lot of stuff.
It's pretty much how do we take people
coming in from all sorts of different
backgrounds. Some people know math from
a different area but have terrible
programming. Some people have strong
like a systems background but no math.
Some people have both but have never
done research, right? Um, so it's just
trying to take all these people from
different backgrounds and just get them
up to speed on this is how you get into
reinforcement learning. This is how you
get from wherever you are to the cutting
edge of the field. And uh, I mean, you
can apply RL using that. You can help us
with research. There's not really any
difference. RL is not an area where like
if you know a little bit, you can apply
it. If you know more, you can do
research. You kind of just have to be
good to make anything work. So there's
not really two separate paths there.
Can I just read this out loud?
Why not? This article is a prequel to my
opinionated reinforcement learning
guide. Exists because people have asked
for me for it repeatedly. Start here if
you A do not know how to program, B
don't know ML, or C started reading the
main article and were confused. C, A,
and B. How to learn to program. Having a
PhD in AI does not mean you know how to
code. Having access to an LLM also does
not mean you know how to code. Thinking
that either of these do is probably a
negative signal in general. Being a
programmer is harder than being good.
Being a good programmer is harder than
being good at AI. Every good programmer
who has started doing RL with us has
done very well. Most of programming is
very simple. Simple does not mean easy.
The thing that makes programming hard is
that it is often terribly taught in a
way that trains you to over complicate
everything. unlearning this takes either
years of failure and pain or a
particularly open mind. Your entire
outlook on how to program could be
stupid and wrong. If you're brand new to
programming, you have an advantage here.
If you are not new but are reading this
anyways, I invite you to make this
decision now. So yeah, all these
articles are written to be very like
they're written as provocatively as
possible while being like strictly true
or strictly true in accordance to my
experience because uh part of that is
because I like doing that. But the other
part of this is like I really think that
this needs to be a sort of a mold
breaker kind of a thing. The way we do
our stuff in RL is not the way that it's
done anywhere else. And flipping that
perspective is very hard and it needs to
be told bluntly.
How to learn. Thank you very much. My
eyes completely went over that. Thanks,
Nick. If any of you see typos or things,
please let me know.
Programming is the act of writing down
instructions that operate on data. The
list of instructions is relatively
short. Create variables by assigning
data to addresses in memory. Evaluate
conditions on variables. Loop over
conditions to run the same set of
instructions many times. Group
instructions together into functions.
Can learn the tools of the trade within
a few hours. But apply applying them
effectively is the pursuit of a
lifetime. Skill in programming is not is
not logarithmic. A bad programmer
creates problems. A good programmer
solves problems. A great programmer can
change the world with nothing more than
a laptop. Enough philosophy. Here are my
top 10 suggestions.
Learn by doing. Start with something
that will take you a few hours. Build up
to something that will take you a few
days. Simple games are great because you
get a quick feel, a a quick visual
feedback. Wait, because you get quick
visual feedback for most problems. I'd
suggest using Ray for rendering.
Lightweight, available in nearly every
language. The library itself is a great
example of well-designed software. Start
with Python. A lot of experienced devs
hate Python. I sometimes hate Python,
too. You should start with Python
anyways because it will let you get
started faster than almost anything
else. Most AI projects you encounter
will have at least the top layer written
in it. But don't spend too long in let's
Python here. But don't spend too long in
Python. Design of a language pushes you
towards a specific way of thinking about
problems. Avoid heavy external packages,
inheritance, checker, decorators, and
generally anything else that takes you
away from learning to express logic in
terms of assignment conditions and
iteration.
and functions. Write a couple basic
games, applications, or tools and move
on. Use UV for package management. Learn
C early. C is a wonderfully simple
language for writing high performance
software. The only reason I don't
suggest learning C first is that it
requires you to learn a bit more about
how computers and operating systems work
pretty much all at once when you're new.
A short list of concepts that you
understand types, type cast struck,
single pass compilation, linking, memory
allocation, stack versus heat point
pointers.
Avoid C++ for now. It's C with a ton of
extra stuff bolted on that you mostly
don't need.
Avoid abstraction. Always aim to solve
the problem at hand in the simplest way
possible.
Do not introduce complexity for the sake
of generality unless you know for sure
that the eventuality you're planning for
will actually arise. Even then, it is
often better to beat that horse when it
arrives. C is great for this because it
takes away most of those tempting
self-defeating tools like inheritance in
heavy third party libraries.
Use a debugger. A debugger allows you to
run your code line by line and expect
the value of local variables.
dramatically faster and more flexible
than littering your code with print
statements and allows you to jump around
quickly. PDB for Python or GDB for C
will suffice. Use an address sanitizer
for C. This will give you readable error
messages and is so important that I
would not suggest C without one. That is
true.
Learn basic Unix tooling. Get
comfortable with the command line ASAP.
You don't need to be fancy here. Basic
commands like ls, pwd, cat, head, move,
copy, cd, make, d, top, etc. You'll only
need the top uh the 10 most common
commands 90% of the time. Ideally, use
native Linux if you can. Mac OS is okay.
Windows is not. Use WSL if you do want
if you do not want to do a boot. I'd
suggest a basic Auntu install. Do not go
ham customizing everything. Get
comfortable with your DRO's package
manager, which is probably going to be
apt, not snap. Don't get nerd sniped.
Programmers love inventing clever ways
to do things worse and waste your time,
especially when you're new. Avoid. This
is the one that's gonna get me so much
hate online. It's great. Object-oriented
and functional programming. They're both
dogmas. Test-driven development. Writing
a few tests is fine. Language and dro
hopping. Industry best practices. There
are plenty of terrible fang engineers.
Python's typ
and C. Make and see. Fancy config
parsers like Hydra. Git subm modules and
fancy CI. Modern web development
frameworks like React. Learning basic
HTML and CSS is a good idea. Pricing.
the latest new programming trend on X
and everything else I rant about on my
dev live streams.
Use Git. This one is so basic that I
almost forgot to include it. Make new
projects on GitHub by default and commit
frequently. This is the best way to
avoid losing work. It also gives you a
version history for when you inevitably
break something that used to work. All
open source projects are run through
GitHub.
Don't grind leak code to learn. It can
be a necessary evil for job interviews,
but solving tricky problems with clever
algorithms really isn't a good
representation of programming as a
whole. You should absolutely learn basic
data structures and algorithms, but
mastering 10 flavors of dynamic
programming isn't going to be as useful
outside of interviews as building more
projects. I haven't taken a programming
interview in years, but I'm certain
18-year-old me would do better than
28-year-old me despite not being able to
build much.
Something like that.
It should be earlier on.
Yeah, I just I put the language levels I
put the two languages together.
I kind of did like a This is less
chronological. This is more like in
order of importance, I guess.
Not that many people I don't think there
are that many people that screw up and
like don't use Git. I had seen it
happen, but it's nowhere near as common.
I think in order of importance, these
are about correct.
Don't worry too much about IDEs. It
really doesn't matter that much. I use
Neoim with a grand total of two plugins.
It's lightweight and stays out of my
way. Yes, I've used plenty of IDs. No,
it doesn't matter. VS Code is fine. Just
run stuff through the terminal instead
of project configurations and buttons.
This will break break the illusion that
the IDE is a magical required tool. Do
not use an AI first editor. Once you've
learned the basics on your own, a code
completion tool like C-pilot or Super
Maven is fine. Use it to save typing and
documentation lookups, not thinking.
Uh, okay. In that case,
I will put this
How to learn ML.
Becoming an effective researcher is
actually easier than becoming a good
programmer. Most researchers are very
bad programmers. Good programmers have a
much easier time becoming good
researchers than bad programmers. I
became a good researcher before I became
a good programmer. I wish I had put more
time into becoming a good programmer
first. Unlike in general programming,
the resources available for ML are
actually pretty good. Uh, Stanford
CS231N lectures are available for free
online. Watch the ones by Andre or
Justin. I never know if his name is
Andre or Andredge
despite me having uh interned in Vay's
lab while he was still a PhD student.
Also, actually do the problem sets. This
is mandatory. Look, I do not like most
courses. This one is good. It is
designed to teach you things without
being particularly challenging. You need
to know what a partial derivative is,
what a matrix is, and that is about it.
Don't worry if you haven't seen a
derivative applied to a matrix
expression before. It is the same as
applying it to a single variable except
that sometimes you transpose the matrix.
It's really not any harder than that.
Who's Justin? Justin Johnson.
The in the same cohort, if you will, as
Andred.
If you're in vision and you know the uh
the clever data set, he built that.
He did that. He did visual genome. He
did a bunch of other stuff.
I interned with Justin
um
when I was in high school and then I did
a little bit of research with him
after that.
I wasn't very good back then, mind you,
but I did what I could.
Once you've completed CS231N,
you'll understand how Autograd works
because you built one and be comfortable
with PyTorch because you'll have used it
to build other things. Congratulations,
you're out of useful course material.
The next step is to start reading
academic papers on archive. Interested
in a specific area of AI? Search around
for a list of the most important papers
and read them. This will be overwhelming
at first, but it will get easier over
time. I've provided you a list for
reinforcement learning in the main
article above. My best general advice
all revolves around the understanding
the limitations of the scientific
process. I've been very intentional with
my wording. Reread these three
paragraphs periodically until you see
for yourself where they came from.
Wasn't my first search result.
Well, if you just look up CS231N,
You can't understand how science is
done. Can't understand papers without
understanding the circumstances under
which they are written. Most conferences
enforce an 8 to nine page limit since
most archive papers are also either
published or were intended for
publication. You'll notice that they are
also 8 to nine pages. Why not shorter
even for simple ideas? Because that is
both an upper and lower limit. Writing a
six-page paper will get you uh will
normally get you rejected. Why do so
many papers have excessively formalized
math even when it's not relevant or
helpful? Because reviewers like to see
formulas. Also, some researchers just
like writing them. Why is the paper
missing X obvious ablation or control
experiment? Because the overworked grad
student who wrote it ran out of time in
GPUs, mostly GPUs. Why aren't there more
papers in X area? Reviewers don't like
those. Oh, also plenty of papers are
just wrong. But when two papers have
appear to have directly contradictory
results, that's probably be that's
because they probably are. Don't trust
prestige. You should care about my
opinion based on what I've provably
built. I use my academic credentials
because unfortunately that's what a lot
of people look at. I'm perfectly
positioned to tell you not to trust
papers from X conference or Y University
by default. It's a weak signal at best
and I've been burned replicating bogus
results from people who should
absolutely know better. While less
common, people do sometimes straight up
lie to get their work published. More
often, it's a combination of noisy
experiments and wishful thinking induced
by six months of long hours at the lab.
The best indicator that a work is
correct is open source code with
multiple independent replications and
usage and follow-up work. But this still
isn't a perfect signal, and I've been
burned here, too. Replicating the
results of papers is a great way to
learn, but know that this can take
months. Absolutely implement some of the
more basic papers when learning a new
area, though.
do this instead. Look for errors. Assume
publications are wrong by default and
find the skeletons in the closet. Are
the experiments poorly controlled? Are
the baselines too weak? Is the reasoning
provided the only plausible explanation
for the results? Work to decouple the
content of the paper from its usually
over complicated presentation. To the
extent that the paper is correct, how
does it fit in with surrounding works?
Building intuition is a combination of
validating claims and pattern matching.
You can think of this as estimating the
probability that a specific direction or
method is worth your time. The greatest
opportunity arises or the greatest
opportunities arise when all the papers
in a specific area are making the same
error. This usually happens when the
premise of a topic or the standard
evaluations are fundamentally flawed.
Great researchers can pierce the veil of
collective myopia to strike out in new
directions.
Cool. I think we are we're good with
this. I can go through just the intro
section of the opinionated RL guide and
then I'm going to have to go for my
meeting.
Uh unless he's canceled. Let me make
sure that I don't have a cancellation.
An ultra opinionated guide to
reinforcement learning. Reinforcement
learning. I'd suggest sending it to your
favorite LLM for proof meeting. Yeah, I
do that. Um, it's kind of annoying.
Like, it's tough to get them to just get
typos and not do anything else.
Oh, uh, by the way, that's actually how
one of my papers got rejected, funny
enough, is a reviewer put my paper into
an LLM for proof reading. It
hallucinated a bunch of typos that were
not in my paper. So, they basically
went, "Ah, this is a sloppy paper." And
gave me a bad review that biased the
other reviewers.
So, uh, yeah, LM are really
dumb.
Some users are like that, too.
H Yeah. Well, people are dumb as well.
We're all dumb. Let's strive to be less
so.
Reinforcement learning is hard, and most
of the material out there for beginners
makes it even harder. The advice here is
a formalized version of how I train new
Puffer Lib contributors. Some of these
came in with zero programming knowledge
and now help advance our research and
tools. The key is to start doing
reinforcement learning immediately while
filling in knowledge gaps slowly and in
order of relevance.
First, the content here is a radical
departure from all other RL books,
tutorials, and references. This field is
broken. Let me say that again. This
field is broken. Mainstream deep
learning has high quality resources,
generally sane approaches to most common
problems, and a pipeline to start
quickly doing useful work. The standard
advice for newcomers in RL may as well
just be designed to wait. The standard
just be designed to screw with you.
You will understand why by the end of
this. Second, this guide assumes that
you are a competent programmer, have
seen at least C or C++ in a systems
course somewhere, have basic deep uh
deep learning knowledge at the level of
Stanford CS231N.
My definition of competent includes many
undergrads and excludes many well-paid
ML engineers. Is a quick lit litmus
test. Can you implement the forward pass
of an LSTM without importing anything?
If not, or if the implementation you
just thought of would be greater than
100 lines, start with the prequel
article, my advice for programming in
ML. And finally, since I'm writing this
for a broader audience, hi, I'm Joseph.
After finishing my PhD at MIT, I've
started a quest to make RL fast and
sane. Most of my content focuses on the
cutting edge of RL, but this has become
surprisingly accessible lately. If you
haven't heard of it already, Puffer Lib
is my main project. is a reinforcement
learning library that is both simpler
and a thousand times faster than other
libraries like SP3, RLI, etc. We're
always looking for new contributors. So
follow me here and join
discord.gg/puffer
to get involved. The best way to support
my work for free in less than 5 seconds
is star puffer on GitHub and retweet
this article. Perfect. So
I got to run for uh meetings. The one I
disagree with is React, but it's your
advice to give. I just the modern. Okay,
to be fair, I don't do a ton of web, but
everything I've seen about the web makes
me like want to yeet my computer and
never touch like programming again. Like
the modern web stack is disgustingly
horrible and like basically every single
good practice and every bit of advice in
front end is just like how to over
complicate everything and make your life
hell. So, I don't know.
Like there are absolutely React devs
that don't know how to program. Like
they just know React for instance.
Okay. Um thank you to everyone here for
tuning in. This was just quick stream. I
have a couple meetings. I will be back
for one or two more sessions afterwards.
Uh we're going to finish this. I'm going
to probably edit up my paper. So, if you
want a sneak peek at the Puffer Lib
publication, I'll be doing that since,
yeah, I'm allowed to do that. There's no
longer a single blinder requirement
because it's accepted. Uh, if you're
interested in my content, you want to
help me out for free, like it said in
the article, puffer.ai, I start the
repo.